nous sommes le 20 mars l'hiver est
officiellement est terminée début du
printemps et dans les titres de cette
édition du journal de la rédaction la
lune alignée entre la terre et le soleil
un phénomène des clips ce qui s'est
produit pour la première fois depuis 99
mais difficile à observer deux par la
météo dans quelques mois les cours vont
être terminées les étudiants recherchent
un job d'été nous irons à montigny le
bretonneux où vient de se tenir informé
puis il est étudiant au lycée hôtelier
de guyancourt il vient de décrocher le
titre de champion de france des desserts
et baptiste vial sera l'invité du jour
pour la première fois depuis 1999 le
ciel français devaient s'assombrir en
pleine journée en ce 20 mars la météo
n'a pas aidé petite déception pour les
amateurs pour les spécialistes encore
plus grande nous étions aux côtés du
club d'astronomie véga 7 à plaisir
un événement exceptionnel pour un
phénomène rare l'association v
gastronomie avait programmé une matinée
spéciale au château de plaisir pour voir
l'éclipsé solaire de ce vendredi 20 mars
une conférence sur ce thème était
organisée pour expliquer le phénomène
aux petits comme aux grands
généralement une configuration de entre
la terre la lune et le soleil à
l'endroit de l'est a lieu tous les trois
cent cinquante ans c'est à dire que la
dernière éclipse qui a lieu ici en ce
moment a eu lieu sous louis xiv à
l'extérieur les télescopes dernière
génération étaient de sortie pour
l'occasion alors à l'intérieur de cette
lunette se trouve l'atmosphère
d'hydrogène ionisé qui ne laissent
passer qu'une longueur d'onde très
précises ce qui vous permet d'étudier
toute la surface extérieure du soleil
après plusieurs minutes d'attenté
d'espoir la météo n'a finalement pas
permis d' observer cette éclipse solaire
les passionnés d'astronomie ont dû se
contenter de la regarder à travers leurs
smartphones et leurs tablettes une vraie
déception pour ces passionnés
d'astronomie
en 30 journées pour pas aller travailler
et puis pour être prêt pour le public
pour l'association pour soi même aussi
parce que c'est un c'est un phénomène
rare et puis c'était les bons créneaux
horaires le soleil était assez haut le
phénomène assez impressionnant puisqu'on
à la lune qui vient sur 80% du disque
solaire on a même noté tout à l'heure un
peu d'assombrissement qui correspond
bien au fait que le soleil était bien
masquée par le par la lune et puis bah
on voit rien
après c'est pas grave moi je suis
content je la ferai des choses il faudra
patienter quelques années pour voir la
prochaine éclipse le soleil rencontrera
une nouvelle fois la lune le 3 septembre
trouver un petit boulot pour l'été cela
s'anticipe les plus prévoyants et est au
pôle jeunesse de montigny le bretonneux
mercredi cette semaine donc pour le
traditionnel forum qui est proposé est
dalo la l'élaboration des cv petites
annonces le reportage de michael et demi
d'euros et de mathilde capbern
un vrai succès le forum sur les jobs
d'été du pôle jeunesse de montigny le
bretonneux a attiré près de 150
personnes mercredi après midi au total
une cinquantaine d'offres d'emploi était
affiché sous une tente installée pour
l'occasion les annonces concernaient
principalement les secteurs de
l'hôtellerie de la restauration et de
l'animation en fait il ya des pistes de
secteurs qui recrutent avec des liens
qui renvoient vers des sites internet ou
des offres sont mises à jour et une
sélection d'offres locales mais aussi
sur paris les parcs d'attractions le
château de versailles après c'est aux
jeunes faire la démarche d'écrire de
postuler et en dehors de cette journée
on peut les accompagner aussi dans la
réalisation du cv de la lettre de
motivation jusqu'à ce qu'ils trouvent
ce qui correspond à leur recherche en
fait parmi les visiteurs beaucoup
d'étudiants la plupart des jeunes
présents ce mercredi cherche un moyen de
se faire un peu d'argent pendant la
pause estivale il y avait l'offre du
conseil général mais bon après il faut
un an de permis j'ai pas encore été
remis mais sinon il ya des offres plutôt
intéressante enfin moi je suis pas à la
recherche d'un truc bien déterminé on
s'est vraiment pour travailler puis
avoir d'expérience peu importe voilà
découvrir ballon j'avais trouvé mais
j'avais du mal et c'est pour commencer
les recherches tôt pour danser mais ça
fait toujours en plus par rapport à ce
qu'ils n'ont pas fait pour postuler pour
des emplois qu'on aura notre réponse
sachant plus quoi si vous avez manqué ce
forum jobs d'été à montigny pas de
panique le pôle jeunesse accompagne
gratuitement les jeunes de 12 à 25 ans
dans leur recherche d'emploi pour la
saison estivale situé sur le parvis des
sources le centre est ouvert du lundi au
vendredi
deux journées studieuses dans le
laboratoire du lycée hôtelier de
tonneaux se sont disputés donc là bas
les finales juniors et professionnels du
championnat de france du dessert les
palmarès ont été divulgués par thierry
marx et chez les juniors baptiste vial
du lycée hôtelier de guyancourt s'est
imposée bonjour et bienvenue vous avez
triomphé donc sur cette compétition
comment vous avez vécu ce concours
beaucoup de stress déjà beaucoup de
stress c'est sûr mais une très bonne
expérience et je j'étais content de ma
prestation juste après la finale je
n'avais pas encore les résultats mais
pour moi j'avais déjà gagné sur déjà de
de l'emporter non non pas du tout c'est
une surprise la nuit résultats bruts
surprise d'ailleurs pas tous les
candidats on était on savait pas qu'ils
pouvaient gagner tellement le niveau
était élevé et serré et voilà justement
peut-être un mot sur thierry marx le
chef doublement étoilé c'est une
pression supplémentaire
oui c'est sûr ce pitch de départ c'est
quelqu'un de très humain et très ouvert
il a été rassurant oui pas trop trop de
pression non ça va je sais quoi la
consigne la conseille donc pour le
panier surprise
il voulait un dessert gourmand
visuellement mais très peu sucré et très
léger pour une fin de repas qu'on a
travaillé là dessus et surtout
amusez-vous pendant le concours c'est ce
que j'ai c'est ce que j'ai pu faire avec
mon nom commis pour d'autres les preuves
il y avait deux réalisations à faire
pendant la compétition on va voir les
photos des deux desserts ci qui vont
s'afficher à l'écran comme ça vous allez
pouvoir nous commenter tout d'abord la
première réalisation alors alors ça
c'est une desserte de sélection donc
celui que j'ai pu créer donc l'intitulé
c'est fraîcheur de pondichéry qui porte
le nom de la ville indienne où j'ai pu
j'ai pu aller en exploitation pour le
moment donc les goûts il y avait de la
mangue du citron vert et du basilic vous
auriez pu venir avec sur le plateau
et voilà j'y joue aussi sur les textures
donc l'on peut apercevoir le sorbet
quelque chose de frais glace et de la
gelée avec de la mangue parfait glacé
citron vert mousse mangue et beaucoup de
croustillant avec les tuiles de sable et
le florentin déjà ça donne l'eau à la
bouche il ya une deuxième réalisation
qui a été fait également pour la
compétition va voir la seconde photo
vous allez pouvoir également nous nous
présenter ce dessert la
voilà donc ça c'est le dessert panier
surprise qu'on connaissait pas on avait
14 minutes pour trouver une idée ça m'a
tout de suite inspiré donc j'ai pu faire
en base c'est une tarte chocolat
composé de mousse cuite croustillant
chocolat ils gagnent h et au dessus un
parfait glacé vanille avec un sorbet
pomme richie est une petite île en forme
de pomme et un décor de coulis voir
comment ça se passe justement l'épreuve
en elle-même vous êtes tout seul vous
avez deux lettres vous avez mentionné le
comique tout à l'heure exacte plusieurs
comment ça se passe concrètement si on
est plusieurs chaque candidat a commis
qui est très très important et
d'ailleurs je les remercie à la fin j'ai
gardé contact avec liszt est quelqu'un
de très bien et le but donc il y avait
plusieurs barème en fait et la gestion
du coni comme y compte beaucoup en plus
de l'hygiène du goût
plein plein de bars les changes comme
d'en bas comme dans une vraie cuisine en
fête trudeau lien il faut pouvoir
communiquer tout de même c'est une
longue préparation vous avez travaillé
combien de temps en amour on arrivait
sur la compétition huit mois c'est vrai
que c'est une longue préparation
je ne sortais plus beaucoup mais là vous
allez vous rattraper il faut fêter le
titre c'est ça oui le travail paye au
final ça me fait plaisir ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui maintenant fin le jour de
la compétition il ya eu beaucoup
d'automatismes aussi il ya beaucoup de
choses qui étaient répétées aux presque
au millimètre près vous saviez président
se bat déjà le dessert de sélection il
fallait que je le connaisse à la lettre
pour pouvoir le faire faire par mont
comi parce que le jour de la finale le
commis doivent plus travailler sur le
dessert qu'on connaît nous et moi au
contraire travailler plus sur le panier
que je ne connais pas effectivement il
fallait bien maîtriser l'ensemble de
votre dessert de votre création un
souvenir de desserts justement votre
premier souvenir de dessert
mais derrière moi papa de desserts que
vous avez réalisé mais le premier
dessert vous avez goûté premier league
alors moi c'est le macaron c'est pas
forcément le dessert c'est une
pâtisserie mais le macaron ici si ça qui
m'a marqué qui m'a donné envie de c'est
ça qui est l élément déclencheur à
travailler autour du macaron alors parce
que n'a pas encore j'en ai pas mal fait
mais c'est vrai qu'il faudrait que tu me
pose les questions pourquoi retravaillé
mais caron leur tour maintenant au lycée
hôtelier maintenant que la compétition
est terminée comment ça s'est passé ce
retour bas on a fait la fête en cuir et
le lycée fier de faire de votre réussite
ici très fier mais je suis fier aussi de
pouvoir voir donner envie aux futures
générations qui pourront le faire
j'espère pouvoir les coachs et l'année
prochaine où les années d'après
il y aura une implication va y avoir un
suivi parce que l'année prochaine
d'aller pas forcément défendre votre
titre il y aura un autre représentant du
lycée hôtelier qui va tenter de vous
prendre ce titre est de gagner votre
place vous aller échanger travailler
passer le relais justement oui je pense
que c'est travailler avec le candidat de
l'année prochaine et en plus de ça bouge
je suis jury de dégustation pour la
finale opposera biarritz à la prochaine
voilà j'ai essayé de faire avancer et
progresser dû transmettre ce que j'ai pu
apprendre et peut-être un défi encore
pour vous le professionnel la catégorie
professionnelle a été remportée cette
année par un ancien lauréat de la
catégorie juniors ça vous donne envie de
faire le doublé aussi dans quelques
années ah oui ça c'est sûr il a été très
émue et ça m'a ému aussi ça donne envie
peut-être dans cinq ou dix ans je sais
pas refaire refaire le championnat en
seniors cette fouille pourquoi pas le
gagner comme ça vous auriez réaliser le
doublé merci baptiste vial d'être passé
en plateau du lys ateliers de guyancourt
vous pourrez bien évidemment revenir
nous en parler mais cette fois ci ce
sera avec les desserts dont je m'en fous
ne viendrai pas en plateau merci à vous
envoie politique et pour continuer le
journal dimanche premier tour des
départementales encore quelques heures
pour pouvoir obtenir établir une
procuration pouvoir vous exprimer même
si vous êtes absent cet important les
explications
les élections départementales sont
programmées les dimanches 22 et 29 mars
si vous ne pouvez pas vous rendre
physiquement dans votre bureau de vote à
ces dates il existe le vote par
procuration
le principe une personne appelée le
mandant désigne un mandataire qui votera
à sa place la procédure a été simplifiée
depuis l'année dernière donc il suffit
de se rendre au commissariat ou à la
gendarmerie avec donc une pièce
d'identité et le cerfa donc cerfacs on
peut remplir en ligne sur internet ou
directement sur place
au commissariat ou la gendarmerie
donc cette personne donc le mandant
donne procuration à une personne qui est
le mandataire et ce mandataire donc ça
peut être n'importe quelle personne
inscrits sur les listes électorales et
domicilié sur la même commune que le
mandant ça peut être n'importe qui ça
peut être un collègue un voisin un ami à
condition que cette personne qui va
voter pour vous soient inscrits sur les
listes électorales il faut à la
procédure validée par les services de la
mairie le mandataire peut officiellement
voter le jour du scrutin la personne le
mandataire donc arrivée au bureau de
vote avec sa pièce d'identité sa carte
d'électeur donc elle précise dans le
bureau de vote qu'elle va voter donc
pour quelqu'un donc ensuite dans les
bureaux de vote il ya des vérités des
étapes de vérification pour voir qu'on a
bien cette procuration et que les noms
coïncident et ensuite la personne peut
voter
à la place de quelqu'un d'autre au total
5 à 8 % des personnes inscrites sur les
listes électorales devrait voter par
procuration pour les élections
départementales cette année ça
fonctionne très très bien on a
énormément de procuration que ce soit
donc pour les élections municipales de
2014 et pour cette année on en a quand
même de plus en plus ça si vous n'avez
pas encore fait votre demande de
procuration pas de panique vous pouvez
envoyer les documents jusqu'à la veille
du scrutin toutefois les responsables de
l'état civil recommande de remplir votre
procuration 3 à 5 jours avant pour
pouvoir traiter l'ensemble des demandes
et dimanche dès 19h45 je vous donne
rendez vous sur cette antenne pour une
soirée spéciale premier tour des
départementales en direct les
responsables politiques viendront sur ce
plateau nos équipes seront en duplex
dans les principaux cantons du
département une soirée à suivre
également en simultané en direct sur
radio sensations
98.4 d'ici là très bon week end le
journal lui revient à lundi dès 18
heures